du glückliches österreich alles kurbel
so heißt es hier zu hause den pcr test
machen und nebenan im laden einfach
abgeben
ich bin deutscher ich heute mein
röhrchen abgeben
das kenne ich normalerweise aus der
kinderwunschklinik das weiß das letzte
mal sowas abgewunken
man hat ja so viel zu tun die arbeiten
naja
das kann doch nicht sein so einfach soll
das gehen und dann auch noch bei den
ossis verkehrte welt
[Musik]
das heißt alles kurbelt alles so lecker
ist das ein google system eine
flüssigkeit ist die man sich selbst in
der rache nimmt spült das dann in eine
projekte die wird abgegeben und gegen
das lager und wird analysiert ok und das
soll besser sein als so ein antigen
testen hier ok ich als engagierter
journalist lese zeitung verfolge die
medien und habe feststellen müssen dass
tatsächlich in deutschland so viel
getestet wird wie bei ihnen an einem tag
in wien was natürlich beschämend ist wie
geht denn das eigentlich jetzt mit
diesem tollen also sagen wir okay dieser
ganze kram dieser anstieg gen test aus
deutschland das ist nix jetzt geht es
ihr das hier ich hab was kostet das gar
nichts vivas service des
gesundheitssystems für die menschen im
moment also die menschen wenn sie kosten
rund wenn ich in deutschland pcr test
machen dann zahl ich 70 euro
und hier kommt wiens gesammelte spucke
an über eine halbe million röhrchen am
tag professor habel und seine leute
brauchen 16 stunden dann hat man das
ergebnis alles ganz einfach
[Musik]
inthermo zyklen der unterschiedliche
temperaturen ab fahren kann und die
fluoreszenz kurven werden dann
entsprechend dem es zum zweiten haben
wir auch eine in liberec onshore diese
fluoreszenz kurse hinter jedem röhrchen
und welt steht dann nach der barcode
visueller mensch das war
quasi aus dem kräuter aber
trotzdem zum ding kostet 70 euro oder
kostete er weniger die zahlen im
augenblick inklusive transport logistik
beschaffung materialien lagerkosten etc
sind wir im augenblick unter knapp unter
sechs euro pro test
also ganz ehrlich gesagt selber sechs
euro wie sollen das gehen also das wird
man gern den deutschen freunden zukunft
sagt nachbar und auf gut wienerisch
gesagt markt zur sache machte sein
verhält man kannte so wir haben das
gesetz nicht mehr innerhalb von acht
wochen acht wo er so was wieder haben
auf die auf die grüne wiese stehen kann
ok österreich hier ist der deal hier
testet ab jetzt unsere spucke dafür
nehmen wir euch die korona schwaben
querdenker paradies da kann man doch
wirklich da so leben wie wie sie sich
denn vorstellen
wir schaffen das nicht mit der pcr test
ist wird wahrscheinlich linie im pflicht
geben in deutschland also von daher
gesehen israeli paradies für sie sie
brauchen auch fachkräfte durchschnitt
was ich gehört habe ja selbst ein
prozent der deutschen überlegen das land
zu verlassen von daher könnte ich sie
gut gebrauchen ich bin 2009 guter mann
aus deutschland vor der merkel diktatur
geflohen wir haben sie stets zurück
können sie von der polizei
[Musik]
daran dass das deutschland umziehen
was sollen wir denn machen sollen wir
komplett wien entvölkern sommer zwei
millionen darüber ziehen damit in
sachsen noch mehr leute spazieren gehen
und dann sich von der polizei verprügelt
lassen das würde ich einen faszinieren
gedanken ich bin einmal vor einer
diktatur geflohen ein zweites mal tue
ich das nicht die nächste diktatur hat
ein problem und das problem bin ich naja
egal ob die korona sportler jetzt nach
deutschland kommen oder nicht hier in
wien ist immer ein plätzchen für sie
frei servus wir sehen uns
[Musik]
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher